- Tuesday morning, Chicago,
a bunch of meetings.
And then flying home, heading
to London tomorrow, first
thing in the morning.
(camera whooshes)
I wasn't done, businessman
life, hashtag that shit.
♫ We're unstoppable
(soft instrumental music)
First Wine Club is going
out, that's super fun.
Ryan did you order the Wine Club?
- I have not yet.
- What the fuck? That just...
- I was supposed to,
and you, what happened?
- What happened was you're
not really my friend.
You don't care about me or drinking wine
at a better price point
than you are normally.
You know, it's $55 a month
and shipping included.
- [Ryan] And what do you get for it?
- One, two, three, or
four bottles a month.
And next month, it's gonna be four bottles
all built for your Thanksgiving.
- Can you have Tyler email
me, I'm just gonna send
it to Mark and help us out quick.
Just tell him to email
me the link or whatever.
- Sold. (laughs)
- (laughs)
- Dear Tyler, please
cancel Ryan's subscription.
(laughing)
I bought two roses that
are big-time roses.
I think people think about rose just
in the Spring and the Summer,
but big-time complement
with like an aperitif
or a lot of the stuff
that people drink at Thanksgiving.
So I'm gonna pink up people's turkeys.
Good morning Instagram,
hope everybody's doing...
Oh we're here, thank you so much.
So you're with us the whole time?
- [Woman] Yes.
- Great, so I'll just leave the bags then.
Good morning Instagram, good to see you.
Hope everybody's doing super well.
I'm gonna talk about
competition entrepreneurship.
And so the exciting part
is either the wine is free
or the conference is free at
my original stomping grounds.
First 200 people, that's
it locking it down.
8:00 AM to 10:00 AM Saturday October 14,
Springfield, New Jersey, see ya.
(soft instrumental music)
Great meetings at Pepsi Co. Chicago.
Now heading out to more
client stuff for PureWow.
Hope you're doing well YouTube.
(soft instrumental music)
But now what you're
watching is innovation,
innovation, innovation,
features, features, features.
And this poll feature is
super intriguing to me
because it's now starting
to make the Stories function
more interactive, more data
collection, more valuable.
DRock keeps getting kicked out
because we don't have enough spots.
- [DRock] (mumbles)
- [Gary] That's why we have
no footage, just walk in.
(rhythmic instrumental music)
Were you filming?
- No.
- It wasn't filming?
- Are you filming now?
- Yes.
- You guys missed it,
DRock was once again wrong,
and I was once again right.
- I didn't see it honestly.
- What are you talking
about, you were right here.
- I didn't see it, if anything I heard
that DRock was right and Gary was--
- Shutting down PureWow, breaking news.
(laughing)
- (laughs) Brand closed for business.
- Brand closed, PureWow
fails on DRock support.
Everybody here already loves DRock.
- I know that.
- You know, like they all
like him more than me.
It's like that whole like thing.
It happened with Mott
on Wine Library TV too,
that's just how it always is.
You're like, "Oh I like that guy better."
- You know? Which is...
- Not better.
- He's also just a nicer guy.
- Better at sucking.
- [DRock] That's true, right, I am.
- He's just like a better
dude overall, you know?
- No, I don't think so, and
DRock's an amazing dude.
- He's pretty amazing.
- But he has some shortcomings.
(dramatic orchestra music)
- What are his shortcomings?
- On episode 307 I'll expose them all.
(laughing)
Ryan, let's talk about how this
was really our hardcore trip.
- Yeah.
- Let's sum it up for the
VaynerNation here on DailyVee.
- This was really interesting for me.
- What was most amazing about me?
- (laughs) So this is the first trip
that me and Gary have taken
that's purely PureWow
focused, pun on words.
- [DRock] Did you think of that?
- Yeah, so this was
solely PureWow focused.
And it was super interesting
because he had his gallery PureWow hat on.
You know, I think I'm a good salesperson.
This was fascinating for me,
I saw a different type of seller.
And he makes magic in the
room, it's pretty unique.
He truly is a very good marketer.
He thinks of things on the spot,
when he hears a bit of
information from people,
he's able to really synthesize the room.
- DRock, you know that.
- Yeah.
- And spit it out in a very unique way.
And, you know, I think there's a lot
of people that are really good at that,
but super creative, super creative.
- That's the surprising part, right?
- No, not really, I feel
like, you know what it was?
I knew that you'd be creative.
I mean, you don't get to where you are
without being creative
and being able to sell.
But it was interesting to see you do it
in my world as opposed
to your world, right?
To be able to be a chameleon and do it
in different businesses
is really, really unique.
- We should have Ryan on the
show more often. (laughs)
- So PureWow's now not shut down anymore.
- No, back, we're rekindling the brand.
VaynerX brings back PureWow.
- [DRock] (laughs)
On a serious note, I think
instead of just like a puff piece
for me and propaganda for me,
let's turn this into you guys.
The chameleon part, empathy,
the other person, it all works out.
The reason I'm a good speaker,
it's about the other person.
I'm grounded as a businessman,
I'm a good businessman.
I really know how to run business,
so when I'm in these rooms I'm empathetic
to what they're trying to achieve,
whether sell product or brand.
I can audit very quickly, I'm fast,
that's why I'm great at Q and A.
So in that room, in about two seconds
I understand their
business, it's just true.
And so to me the reason so much is working
for me is I am religious
about the end consumer,
and in a B to B environment
that means their business.
And in the speech, that means
the people in the audience.
And when I create products
like the Wine Club, or 4Ds,
or all these different things,
it's always about the other person.
And the leverage is when
you're more valuable
to the other person than
they are to you, the end.
- Yeah, you know, it's shocking.
I used to think good businessmen
always found a way to,
you know, win a deal or to
figure out the better end.
And something that Gary
does shockingly often
is make sure that he loses deals.
He makes sure that the
other person feels like
they're getting the
better end of the deal.
That they feel like,
not only that they think
they're getting the better end,
but they are getting the
better end of the deal.
So then six months from now
when he really needs to,
he can come back and he can
ask for a favor accordingly.
But it's with the right energy about it.
- You know what's really
interesting about that, man?
Honestly, on a very serious note
because you haven't felt
it full circle, or not.
- Right, 90% of the time you don't do it.
- Just be always in a place
where you have the leverage.
- Yep.
- Like if I get hit by a truck,
and my brain's not as good,
and I'm not good anymore.
Now I'll be like, hey DRock,
hey client, can you help me?
I don't have it anymore.
That's the beauty of
being a businessperson
and not an athlete.
- Yep.
- You get exponentially better
and not slower, and not as good.
- Absolutely.
- It's all about the other person, man.
Run the marathon, not the sprint.
The short deal, where you got the extra.
So much the flaw of so many of you.
You're looking for the
short-term, everybody pounding me,
"Gary do this for me, do this for me."
- It's true.
- How about do something.
That's how DRock's sitting in that seat.
- It's too--
- I way overpaid for PureWow,
he got a much better deal.
- Underpaid.
- Overpaid, overpaid.
- Now. (laughs)
(laughing)
(rhythmic instrumental music)
- Fast, test, learn, do,
it's the same old shit.
300 episodes in, if you still don't know
you better wake the fuck up.
(rhythmic instrumental music)
Hey guys, I interrupt this vlog
to make this important announcement.
A lot of you have a whole lot of excuses
of not being able to produce content.
You know, don't have designers,
don't have this, don't have money.
Here is a post that I posted on Instagram
that's doing super well, and
it is basically the screenshot
of one of my Tweets that
was all written words.
So stop fucking making excuses
and start doing, period.
Now, back to the vlog.
Guys, quick question
of the day in the vlog.
Little new feature here, DRock.
I'm so excited.
What is holding you back from
making more Snapchat content?
Lurkers answer, so many of
you watching this for free.
I'm asking for nothing in return,
and you can't even give me a content
you dirty, dirty lurkers.
Come out, come out, come out
and answer this one today.
What is holding you back
from creating more Snapchat content?
(rhythmic instrumental music)
- End it with that.
- (laughs)
- Oh crap, I have to go
on a phone call anyway.